Пані Деконаідзе, українське суспільство сколихнув черговий скандал,
пов’язаний із застосуванням сили з боку поліцейських.
У Київській області двох поліцейських звинувачують у тортурах
та зґвалтуванні жінки просто у відділку поліції.
Це, на жаль, не поодинокий випадок за останні роки,
коли правоохоронці замість захисту громадян скоюють проти них злочини.
Через такі випадки дедалі частіше лунають сумніви
у ефективності реформи Національної поліції.
Ви були безпосередньо причетні до проведення реформи,
очолюючи Нацполіцію України в 2015-16 роках.
Як Ви реагуєте на такі випадки?
Відверто скажу, що навіть не знаю, як це назвати. Це, звісно, дуже болюче для мене.
Я працювала в національній поліції, представляла Україну.
Я не знаю деталей, але коли такі випадки трапляються,
то виникає багато запитань до того, що відбувається в системі.
Чому? Тому що, коли ми почали реформувати патрульну поліцію, це була перша хвиля реформ.
І це була дуже відкрита реформа.
Коли ми скасували ДАІ і почали реформу патрульної поліції,
коли ми набрали 99 відсотків нових людей, це, я гадаю, вдалося.
Але після першої хвилі, реформи патрульної поліції, більше нічого не було.
Я думаю, що якщо не до кінця довести реформу поліції, то...
Я не хочу казати, що такі жахливі випадки знову будуть,
але, я думаю, що, звісно, в українському суспільстві  виникне багато питань.
Чому нова поліція так і не стала новою?
Ви погоджуєтеся із твердженням, що повертаються старі методи міліції?
Почасти я все ж вважаю, що патрульна поліція стала новою поліцією.
Тому що це була перша реформа в Україні після Майдану, яку реально відчули люди.
Я не хочу сказати, що ми втратили момент…
Я кажу "ми", бо відчуваю себе наполовину українкою.
Але Україна втратила дуже багато часу.
Треба було реформувати поліцію до кінця - не лише патрульну, а й кримінальну.
Кримінальна поліція - це найважливіше.
Адже вона була замішана в корупції, була замішана в рекеті,
у випадках, коли реально йшла проти суспільства.
І вийшло, що поліцейські уявляють собі, що працюють чесно,
але стара система повертається.
Постійно!!! Совкова система нікуди не поділася.
Для того, щоб вигнати совкову систему з правозахисної системи,
як ми це проходили в Грузії,
треба прибрати всю верхівку, в якій існує таке відношення, що система прикриває своїх,
не хоче реформуватися, демонструє фасадні реформи.
Ви говорите про верхівку, яка не сприяє змінам. Кого Ви маєте на увазі?
Це парламент. Верховна Рада, яка може ухвалювати закони,
які дуже необхідні для роботи правоохоронців.
Це, звичайно, президент, прем’єр, ну, політична команда, міністри.
Всі повинні розуміти, що якщо не позбутися совкової структури, то знову втратимо час.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Арсен Аваков займає цю посаду з 2014 року
і у відставку, схоже, не збирається.
Ви розумієте, чому в уряді так довго не змінюється глава МВС?
З чим, по-Вашому, це пов’язано?
Я думаю, що це питання не до мене.
Але у мене враження, з того, що я читаю, знаю про Україну, хоча більшість часу я в Грузії,
що це пов’язано з політикою і політичними впливами.
І це знову стосується теми довіри поліції.
Думаю, якщо остаточно не звільнити правозахисну систему від політичного впливу...
Це не стосується якось конкретної влади. Це може бути ця чи інша, це стосується усіх.
Та сама проблема в нас зараз у Грузії.
Коли правозахисна і судова система повністю під впливом однієї людини,
ви знаєте, олігарха, то тоді нічого не вийде.
Чому, на Ваш погляд, Україні не вдалося провести повноцінну переатестацію
працівників міліції, а старі кадри, всупереч своїй невідповідності професії, повертаються?
Другий етап реформи кримінальної поліції  не тільки не дійшов до кінця,
але були і великі прогалини.
Тому що ми почали переатестацію старих міліціонерів,
яких хотіли призначити на посади в новій поліції.
Ми скоротили, здається, 8 000 старих міліціонерів.
Потім, коли їх почали поновлювати суди на старі посади,
це була теж дуже серйозна проблема.
І зараз у мене немає точної інформації, скільки їх поновлено.
На мій погляд, багато.
І, чесно кажучи, третій етап, коли треба була скоротити вищий склад, верхівку:
начальників областей, їхніх заступників, створити  систему детективів,
синхронізувати розшук і слідчі органи, так до кінця не дійшло.
Чому не вдалася переатестація? Стара система просто так не йде.
Я думаю, тоді треба було бути більш радикальною і мати якийсь великий тил,
який дозволив би робити зміни нашій команді і не тільки мені.
Коли стартувала Національна поліція, співробітникам обіцяли гарні зарплати
і була надія, що до неї прийдуть нові люди.
Однак у поліції по всій країні вже давно брак  кадрів. Як думаєте, чому?
Куди поділося прагненння людей йти до поліції?
Ви знаєте, я погоджуюся. Коли ми починали все в 15-му році, то мотивація була шалена.
У нас був завал, грубо кажучи, дуже багато людей хотіли йти в патрульну поліцію.
У нас на одне місце було 6-7, а в Києві 10 заявок.
Тоді зарплата, яку ми оголосили, була від 9-ти і до 12 000 гривень ...
Тоді це була нова служба, нові машини, тоді це мотивувало.
Але ще більше людей мотивував абсолютно новий підхід до змін.
Поступово стало важче, тому що зарплати піднімаються, але дуже-дуже повільно.
Якщо поліції не дати нормальні зарплати, нормальне соцзабезпечення,
якщо не полагодити машину, яка розбивається
Якщо не надати гарного тилу, якщо вони бачать, що хтось когось кришує,
що в кримінальній поліції відбувається...
А самі вони працюють чесно.
Ось тоді приходить те, що сталося після першого етапу реформи - демотивація.
Як Ви думаєте, це ще можна змінити?
Безповоротних моментів не буває.
Я думаю, що якщо будуть ось такі реально дуже жорсткі наміри, що треба...
Все! Підійти до цього, як до останнього шансу, то, звичайно, можна довести реформу до кінця,
можна змінити закони, регуляції і провести дуже жорстку реформу в прокуратурі
і судовій системі, це все можна зробити.
В Україні за цей час з’явилося кілька нових антикорупційних органів.
І зокрема Державне бюро розслідувань, що теж є частиною реформи.
Чи вважаєте Ви, що з появою Державного бюро розслідувань,
ситуація із законослухняністю правоохоронців покращиться?
Відверто: якщо є питання до ядра правоохоронної системи,
то паралельні структури, як на мене, не дуже допомогають.
Адже це більше бюрократії, більше поділу відповідальності.
Думаю, треба реформувати ядро і потім додавати.
Після президентських виборів експрезидент Грузії Міхеіл Саакашвілі
зміг повернутися не тільки в Україну, але й до влади.
Як Ви думаєте, він зможе зупинити відкат тих реформ, які пройшли раніше?
Йому дадуть таку можливіть?
Я дуже сподіваюся, що так.
Моя думка, уявлення і дуже велике бажання, щоб Міхеіл підсилив нову команду президента.
Чому? Тому що це важливо для України, і не тільки для України.
Тому що провести реальні реформи і зробити Україну вільною, великою і успішною країною
- важливо для Грузії і регіону.
У нас спільний ворог і один регіон, і ми просто пов'язані дуже тісно.
Тож я дуже сподіваюся, що якісь зміни будуть,
що у нього буде тил від президента, якого він очікує.
І українці чекають, і всі чекають, як я розумію.
Сумуєте за Україною?
Дуже, дуже. Я намагаюся часто приїжджати ...
Коли мене журналісти запитують, мовляв, чому Україна? Навіщо Ви туди поїхали?
Так, я приїхала як технократ, зробила свою роботу, як вважала за правильне.
Але я завжди думала, що ми сидимо в одному човні з Грузією.
І цей човен повинен провезти нас крізь шторми, і ми повинні дійти разом до Європи, до НАТО.
Це моя мрія для України і для Грузії.
І більше того, реформована Україна - це, як сказати, найбільший удар для Путіна.
Це дуже важливо.
Хотіли б знову повернутися в Національну поліцію? Чи в один з офісів реформ?
Не думала про держпосаду, але як як експерт, консультант
завжди допомагала і буду допомагати.
Якщо це буде потрібно Україні, то чом би й ні.
У Вас пропозицій немає, вірно?
Ні.
Дякую дуже!
Дякую, дякую!